Good morning.
I think we'll try to stay on time and go ahead and get started.
It's my honor and privilege to introduce Dr.
Lillian Tsou, who's the current AACR president for
about three more hours or something.
But she really was the person who supported this
topic and doing this as a presidential symposium,
and we're so excited to hear her remarks.
Lillian.
Good morning. I want to thank Ray for agreeing to chair this
exciting symposium.
As you heard that this is actually my last symposium before I
become a past president. The business meeting is right
after this, so I hope you all go to the business meeting as
well. The reason I picked precision-based
prevention as the theme of the President's Select
Symposium is because I think this is an area of research that is so
important, and we are having a lot of strategic planning
right now at AACR, and this rises way to the top in terms of our
priorities. And I think as phase one trialists who treat a
lot of patients in the advanced course of their disease,
this is an area where I really wanted to learn, I really wanted to
understand about early cancer detection and
prevention. And I picked a select symposium
where I think I will learn a lot, and
I'm so happy to see the slate of speakers
we have lined up for you because they are the top
speakers and top experts in this field.
And you'll see that the breadth and depth of their research really makes this
feel really exciting, and I see what is to come in the next decade
will be
really something we should all look forward to.
So I don't want to take up any more of your time.
I'm going to pass it back to my chair, Dr.
Dubois, who has agreed to chair this symposium. Thank you.
Thanks, Lillian. If you look through the progression of the speakers
today, I think you'll realize that there is sort of a logical
transition,
in this area. Like Lillian said, this was really a top
priority in the survey that AACR sent out.
And
we wanted to sort of cover the waterfront here.
So,
initial speaker will talk about early detection and early risk
assessment, even at the neonatal stage.
That's about as early as you can get.
And then once we detect this risk or assess risk or
have a presence of pre-cancer or risk for pre-cancer, what can
we do to intervene? And Sir John Burns is going to give us some information about
what he's done.
Nora Disis is going to speak about how we might be able to arm the immune
system,
and preempt some of these, pre-cancers and other
pre-invasive diseases from occurring.
And then lastly, AI is on everybody's mind.
How are we going to utilize it to detect things better, earlier,
and improve our accuracy, and then maybe even avoid some unintended
harms? So, we'll start off with Dr.
Sharon
Plon from Baylor College of Medicine, in Houston.
And her title is Risk for Pediatric Cancer in
Newborn Screening.
Okay.
Sorry.
Just put it there.
Yeah.
There we go.
Great.
So obviously, you're always really honored when you get an email inviting you to
speak at the Presidential Symposium. So I want to thank Dr.
Tsou and Dr. Dubois for putting this session together.
And my title will give you an idea of where we are, Risk for
Cancer is Finally Being Included in Newborn Screening Trials.
So these are my disclosures.
So as a clinician and many of my colleagues who are in the
room are engaged in cancer predisposition testing and
clinical care for children, we often question, should
newborn screening include testing for cancer
predisposition? And if so, which genes, what
technology in order to implement this in a cost-effective manner?
And if not, which is the current situation, why not?
So just to frame a case, and this is from my colleague Lisa Diller,
who also shared some of her unpublished data for this talk.
This is a boy diagnosed at 18 months with bilateral
retinoblastoma, underwent intensive treatment, including
bilateral enucleations, and was identified to have an RB1
pathogenic variant. His sister was then tested as a
newborn. She was able to have local therapy and
preserve normal vision.
Whoop.
And is the animation not going to work? Okay.
And her mother asked, "Why don't you test everyone for this
disease when they are born?" And that's a question we frequently get
in the children's cancer centers.
So let's talk a little bit about newborn screening because this audience probably
isn't that familiar. It is a process.
Every baby in the United States is approached.
Families are informed, but consent is not required because it's
considered a public health effort, and we get a quality
heel stick on a Guthrie card between 24 and 48 hours
of life.
The hospitals send these daily to,
in the United States, these are state labs, in other countries, they're sometimes
national labs, and the testing is performed there
with lots of need for quality control and data integrity.
If a child is positive, there's another whole team that actually
reaches out. They have to find the baby, because for many of these disorders,
you have to do treatment immediately,
or there's long-term surveillance.So what is the
criteria to be included in newborn screening?
And that comes originally from a paper back in 1968.
It needs to be a clinically important condition.
There has to be a screening test that can be done.
There need to be facilities at hospitals to diagnose and treat the
disorder. The treatment has to be acceptable to the
medical community, and it has to be a condition you can't otherwise
recognize based on physical features or clinical
presentation. You do have to know something about the natural history
of the disorder if a test is positive, and it has to be
cost effective in some way to diagnose and treat.
So what do we currently do? In most states, we test between 50
to 60 different conditions,
often done by tandem mass spec for metabolic disorders.
Some are done by ELISA assays. We now do Treg circles for
SCID, and there's deletion duplication analysis for
SMA. There are almost no primary
sequence-based diagnostic tests being done, and there's no
cancer risk testing at all.
So if we think about childhood cancer, and I'm just quoting some of my own work,
this has been done by many different groups.
This is our data from a thousand patients prospectively
enrolled in with solid tumors in exome sequencing
trials. And overall, 10 to 12% of these
children carry a pathogenic or likely pathogenic variant in a cancer
predisposition gene. If you focus in on just early
onset cancers that would be most amenable to newborn screening, it's
about 5%, with TP53 and RB1
being the most common, APC and DICER being also very
frequently found. Lots of other genes have one to three individuals.
Some people say, "Well, why don't you use family history?" Well, many
of these patients have de novo mutations. That's very common.
80% of patients with RB1. So family history is
irrelevant. And more importantly, in the United States,
many of these patients are diagnosed with advanced tumors or actually from
families with known genetic diagnoses, and that information
was never conveyed to the pediatrician.
And that can be because of low penetrance, or really it's often just they never
think to tell the doctor.
So the question, of course, then becomes, if you're going to do
newborn screening, do we know what to do with the positive children?
And here I do want to acknowledge AACR.
I
know David's here, and maybe Garrett's here, co-chaired a committee of which I was
a member that did two childhood cancer
predisposition workshops, and that included more
than 65 oncologists and other specialists, geneticists,
radiologists,
from 11 countries. And the goal was to develop
evidence-based guidelines for children diagnosed with cancer
predisposition syndromes. We worked closely with AACR and the
Clinical Cancer Research Journal to publish these.
And I'm proud to say that we did develop guidelines for over 50
syndromes. They were first published in 2017, and we
did 20 updates in '24, '25. They're all open
access. Please feel free to photograph the slide.
And these provide standard guidelines starting at infancy for
cancer predisposition in children.
Okay, so now we know the conditions. We have some idea of the rate.
Can we do this? So Lisa Diller and her colleague Jennifer Yeh
published a few years ago a modeling of this using a
next generation sequencing panel for the set of genes in the
middle. They used public databases to estimate their
findings, and then they estimated outcomes and
costs. And overall, they showed that if you did do
new cancer risk newborn screening, cancer deaths before the age of
20 would decrease by 8%. For those with a cancer
predisposition syndrome, it might decrease by as much as
54%, and more adult survivors would be
alive because radiation was avoided, and you knew which
individuals were more likely to develop a second malignancy, and
you also saw an improvement in outcome due to the shift to
earlier stages.
And they found that the cost effectiveness of the testing was almost
completely driven by the sequencing costs, which influenced the
study that we've now put together.
They've also done a retrospective study working with Michigan on their
cancer registry and their newborn blood spot bank,
and they were able to link the blood spots of children who
then developed a tumor by the age of eight, and they
identified almost 2,000 individuals where they were able to
obtain the blood spots. And the laboratory at the Brigham and Women,
and this is data that's currently under review, then did next generation
sequencing of a 3.2 millimeter dried blood spot,
getting adequate DNA to get the results.
They used AI supported variant classification
as well as manual interpretation to call the variant, and then, of
course, analyze the data. So this is just a small snapshot of their
data. First of all, there were concordance of results.
The five children of the 2,000 who had a RET variant all
had medullary thyroid cancer. The much larger number of
children who had an RB1 variant, all had
retinoblastoma or pinealblastoma.
So the genes did in fact match the tumors these children went on to
develop.
Overall, they saw rates that are very similar to what I had reported.
Of the whole cohort of 2,000, about 6.8%
had a pathogenic or likely pathogenic variant in this small
group of genes. And again, these genes were selected because they're associated
with early onset cancer. Genes like BRCA1 and things
like that were not included.They estimate about one
in 30,000 children who
have a positive blood spot might go
on to develop cancer. And that's very
similar to other newborn screening, which includes very, very rare
conditions.
What they don't know is how many positives might not have developed a
tumor, and that's one of the things we're going to look at in our study.
So with all of that, Lisa and I and many of our colleagues in Houston and Boston
got together and proposed to the Alex's Lemonade Stand Foundation
a
study that we now call NCARE with this
multi-institutional team. I do want to point out that we also
included Natasha Bonhomme from Expecting Health.
That organization works to
educate parents on newborn screening.
And we included neonatologists, OBGYNs, geneticists, and
oncologists in our team, as well as epidemiologists.
So what are we proposing to do? And we've just finished our first
year. We're using pooling method for a
population-based cost sensitive testing, thinking again about the
modeling that the cost of the test is a major driver, and I'll
talk about that more in a minute. We then have
identified a very large set of controls from Michigan who
did not develop cancer, so we can now compare what proportion of the
controls might have a positive test.
And we're developing educational materials for parents on
cancer risk newborn screening. We're then proposing to launch
a large prospective clinical trial in Houston and
Boston to assess feasibility of doing this testing at scale.
Our goal is to approach 10,000 mothers of newborns,
measure acceptability for parents for a focused versus broad
testing. And the
focus is like RB1 and WT1, high de novo
rate, high penetrance, early onset.
Genes like DICER1, for example, have very early-- A mother I just
saw on Wednesday said, "Well, not everyone with DICER1 gets cancer."
And her child had a PPB. But in fact, if you
look at the data, the penetrance is only about 10% for any
malignancy. So the larger panel does include genes where
the penetrance is not as high, but there's still risk in early
onset disease, like pulmonary
pleuroblastoma. And of course, we want to identify the potential
harms and risks and the family health impact.
So Andy Bhattacharjee from the Brigham and Women's Hospital
is running the molecular lab for this study.
We're using a pooling test that was published a few years ago in
Genome Medicine, where every sample is in two
pools of 10 samples, and therefore, by looking at
the overall results of these 20 pools
from the 100 samples, you can identify the specific
sample that had to have the mutation.
And this saves you de-convoluting every positive pool.
We're using element sequencing instruments, which are being adapted by
many newborn screening providers.
We are again, using AI driven informatics to aid in variant
classification. And the pipeline is designed to yield cost
of testing within the newborn screening test range.
This is the trial which we hope to get underway in a year, where again,
we're going to randomize mothers to either the focus panel or the full panel,
look at their acceptability of these two options.
We're obviously going to probe reasons for declining.
Everyone will get a baseline
demographic survey, but a subset will get a much more detailed
survey about cancer risk, cancer worry, and then we will
repeat that six months after the test.
We expect very few positives out of 10,000 babies, but if
we do find any, those parents will be interviewed as well as their
pediatrician.
Of course, I'm talking about targeted sequencing, but there's a lot going on
in whole genome sequencing, and this is a graphic from the UK
Generation study about the many steps in doing whole genome
sequencing.
And there are now many genome sequencing studies, but again, they are
reporting very few cancer predisposition genes.
So iCONS is now this international organization of sub
studies, which NCARE is now a member of.
A medical student at Harvard reviewed 22 trials with
available gene lists, and only RB1 was in the
majority.
RET and WT1 were in about half of the studies.
Tuber sclerosis, frankly, was probably there because of the epilepsy risk,
not the cancer risk. So you can see that even in these whole genome studies,
some of which are reporting 400 genes, only one or two
cancer genes are being included.
This is an example from Generation.
They did identify a child with RB1, going back to my first
case. This child was unidentified before this.
Did have small bilateral tumors that were amenable to
simpler, less toxic treatment.
And this has now made the press in the UK and made them
reconsider perhaps adding some additional cancer genes.
In the US, there's a study that was just funded last
summer called BEacons. It's a large NIH funded collaborative
research team. There's seven state labs participating.
They plan to sequence up to 30,000 babies, and the
whole genome sequencing is being done by GeneDx.
And they developed a list of 777 conditions,
which were just announced. I'm happy to say that
Lisa and I both got to participate on the committee.
And there are 19 cancer genes included on this
list.So to finish,
expanded newborn screening clinical trials are beginning to include
genetic risk for pediatric cancer, which represents a potential major
advance in preventive medicine.
Improved sequencing modalities and pooling strategies may enable
cost-effective identification. Remember, the states have to pay for this.
Texas alone has 400,000 babies a year,
so whole genome sequencing is probably not realistic
without NIH support. We hope that it will improve
outcomes with early detection through newborn screening and improve
surveillance using the guidelines AACR helped to develop to
result in better survival with less toxic treatments.
And of course, these children require evidence-based
protocols, attention to incomplete penetrance, and family
support systems. But given the rest of the talks,
this provides exciting new opportunities for cancer prevention
research in children. Thank you.
Thanks, Sharon. Next speaker will be John Burn from Newcastle
University. John's going to talk about therapeutic
precision cancer prevention, the power of canaries.
So...
Thank you, Mr. Chair. Ladies and gentlemen, my name is John Burn.
I'm from the UK. It practically stands for the ungrateful kingdom now.
So I'm going to talk about canaries.
These are my disclosures.
Thirty six years ago, I went to a local coal mine and
asked for a picture of one of their canaries.
I'd just been to see a 12-year-old boy called Jonathan, whose mother had a
panproctocolectomy for familial polyposis.
He had a clear colonoscopy, but he had osteomas just like his mother, which meant
that he was a gene carrier. And it struck me that here was a perfect opportunity to
try prevention strategies, not only to prevent problems
in people with FAP, but also as a model for the general population.
And I persuaded my colleagues, Tim Bishop in Leeds, and John Mather, our
professor of human nutrition, and we identified two potential interventions,
fermentable fiber or resistant starch, and aspirin.
And we set up CAP1, which was eventually published under Ray's
editorship in the,
Cancer Prevention Research quite a long time after.
It was quite a hard trial to do, but it
ironically started recruiting in 1993, just as we were supporting
Kolodner's group to identify the MSH2 gene for Lynch syndrome.
And that was an altogether better target population.
So I persuaded the leaders in that field to come to Newcastle, including Henry
Lynch, and we decided to do CAP2, which would be the same approach
using the same interventions, slightly modified in terms of using enteric-coated
aspirin and a commercially available resistant starch.
And we started that in 1999, and when we eventually
completed recruitment in 2005, we followed through to
2011, when we could see the aspirin was working.
So we then decided to plan a new trial, imaginatively called
CAP3, to do a dose non-inferiority study.
Meanwhile, we finished the CAP2 trial.
We went out to the 10-year unblinding stage, and we
were able, with our national registry, to continue following the English,
Welsh, and Finnish patients through to the next decade.
And you can see that despite the fact we stopped giving them any aspirin after four
years, the benefits were persisting for several years thereafter,
presumably destroying premalignant lesions as a result.
The other thing to remember is that nothing happens for the first four
years. When you do prevention, you don't instantly see an effect.
And that's very important in terms of interpretation because hazard
ratio looks at the first event and therefore is not the
ideal statistical approach. And so we also used incidence
ratio, negative binomial regression, which allows you to account for
all of the cancers rather than just the first one.
The second limb of the trial took a long time to get published, and I'm grateful to
Ray for helping us to find referees who didn't have a religious objection
to randomized control trials involving food.
And we eventually got this published because the primary impact was not as
we expected. It didn't affect the development of colorectal cancer in Lynch
syndrome, but it did rather dramatically impact on our secondary
endpoint, which were the other Lynch syndrome cancers, which were about
50% down. And the biggest impact seemed to be on the upper GI
cancers, hepatobiliary, duodenal.
And we suspected that that might be because we changed the microbiome in
these individuals, and
that resulted in a reduction in the production of carcinogenic secondary
bile acids, which of course recycle through the upper GI
tract. Whatever explanation, having a high fiber diet is great,
but you don't have to eat green bananas. We did get a cover.
I've had more questions about green bananas in the last few years than I ever want
to recount.
Sorry about that.
So
CAP3 was primarily supported by our National Institute of Health
Research, and we recruited across all the genetic centers in the UK,
1,547 people as we were targeting.
We also managed to supplement that with setting the trial up separately in,
as you can see, Australia, Finland, Spain, and Israel.
And all of that data came into the Newcastle database for analysis.
We had lots of discussions about how to design the statistics, and we wanted to
do two separate analyses comparing the 600 milligram dose
with a 300 milligram dose, which we thought would probably work, and
comparing 600 to 100, which we thought might not.
And so we overloaded the 600 milligram group after much
consultation, and randomized on a four to three
basis. We blinded for two years so we could look at the
adverse events, but we kept on going for a further three years so that we could get
the maximum impact across a five-year
follow-up.The randomization went exactly as
we hoped, and as you can see, mostly recruited MSH2 and
MLH1 gene carriers. These are the high penetrance group who tend to be
more seen in our hospitals.
So apologies for the slightly
out-of-focus picture here. This is from our supplementary document which is just
about to appear in "Lancet Gastroenterology." It hasn't quite got out this week.
And the rather surprising result was that we had the fewest Lynch
syndrome cancers in the people on the smallest dose of aspirin.
The 300 milligram group did rather worse, but as you can see, that was mostly
because they went high in the first three or four years when, remember, the
aspirin is not really having much of an effect, and then kind of tracked back into
the confidence intervals of the 600 milligram group thereafter.
This slide includes bladder and prostate cancers, which are now seen as Lynch
syndrome.
The other thing we looked at was a secondary endpoint of colorectal cancers, and
again, the 100 milligram group had the fewest colorectal cancers, which was
obviously slightly surprising, but great news.
Now, this is a slightly complicated slide, but we thought the best way of
representing this data collectively was as a forest plot.
We chose an upper limit, a predetermined upper limit of
1.5. The reason for that was that we saw a 50%
reduction in colon cancer in CAPP2 with 600 milligrams,
but we did a survey of general practitioners of over 1,000 and found that
only 62% of them would be willing to prescribe 600 milligrams of aspirin
even if we told them to. And so if we got a
25% reduction with a baby aspirin, we figured that would be worth having.
And so that was where we set the predetermined limit.
And you can see that the confidence intervals of all of the interventions for Lynch
syndrome cancer, for colorectal cancer, and for all cancers were
inside that 1.5 threshold. That was great until
we got to the referee for "The Lancet."
And it turns out statisticians argue a lot.
And the statistician who was reviewing it said, "No, no, no.
Even though you had a big reference group, it's still multiple testing, so you
have to use 97.5% confidence intervals." So we
did,
and we eventually put both in the paper, which has now got rather long.
The good news is it was still inside the threshold, and in fact,
if you are addicted to HR, it was inside the threshold there as
well, but that's as close as you can get to the threshold without actually going
over it.
The downside of having to go to 97.5% was we slipped
slightly over the line on the per protocol group.
Now, if you're a purist in non-inferiority trials, which I wasn't,
it turns out that you have to get across the line on per protocol as well,
because obviously if you think about it, if everyone just didn't take the tablets,
then everything would be the same, and so you need to know they took the tablets.
But of course, we had the CAPP2 trial, and the CAPP2 trial showed us that the
600 milligram group in CAPP3 did exactly the same as the ones in
CAPP2, so we can be pretty sure they took their tablets.
So the intention to treat data is the reliable result.
The other thing we just did as an afterthought was just said, what if we just put
all of the CAPP3 patients together and looked at their risk
compared to the old CAPP2 graph? And you can see that the
pink confidence intervals here are actually tighter than the CAPP2 data because
it's a bigger series. And in fact, we got an HR of
0.67 comparing all of our CAPP3 patients
to that historic placebo group in CAPP2.
We're going to go on now and assemble a new reference group from our
database I'll tell you about in a moment.
On serious adverse events, the good news was there were none in the 100 milligram
group. Not all of these were due to aspirin.
One of them was someone who fell off his mountain bike, and another one was a
surgeon who cut an artery, but you have to report them all.
But the good news is that we didn't see any major hospital treatment events
of people
in the 100 milligram group. In terms of events of interest, these were
relatively small in number considering we're looking at several, about 8,000
patient years of follow-up, and the majority of these were just complaints about
bruising,
which of course is an inevitable consequence of an antiplatelet dose of aspirin,
something that I think your president has had to draw attention to in the not too
distant future. And speaking of your president, he'll be pleased to know that there
were no cases of autism in our trial.
So in summary, after eight years of treatment, 30% of people
on the smallest dose had the fewest cancers, so we should be recommending low-dose
aspirin to people with Lynch syndrome.
And in the UK, we've already, since most of the people who write the guidelines are
authors on the paper, have already changed our guideline, which will be coming out
online very soon, as soon as the paper arrives.
And we're basically saying give everyone, in your case, 81 milligrams of
aspirin. And we're suggesting that we start at five years prior to
colonoscopy and stop at 70 because, of course, the side effects are much
higher and possibly less efficacious in the older population.
Eradicate H. pylori, deal with blood pressure to cut side effects.
And an interesting, important bit of information we need to build on is
obesity. We think you should double the dose for people with a BMI of
over 30.
Why does it work? Well, I haven't got time in my 15 minutes of fame to discuss all
of these options. It's clearly not COX-2 inhibition because although that did get
me my most cited publication, thanks to Monica,
it isn't usable in our population because of the adverse event
risk. And of course, a small dose of aspirin is not going to block COX-2.
Much interest now in the mTOR pathway after Andy Chan's group first pointed
out that it seems to be the PIK3CA mutated tumors that respond,
and this very nice review explains all of the places where in that
pathway aspirin can have an effect because aspirin is a natural substance.
Our natural diet used to contain a lot of salicylate because
plants produce salicylate to cause apoptosis.
So another question is, is the aspirin enhancing
apoptosis?If that is the case, it would explain perhaps in
part why it works less well in people of my age, because about 10% of
my crypts have no longer got functioning mitochondria, and so
apoptosis fades with age. But the most
interesting, exciting result is what you're going to hear about more from my
partner, Ruth Langley, tomorrow in her presentation, and our partners
at Cambridge, who've demonstrated that in fact it's the activated platelets we need
to watch out for.
So Ruth will be talking about this.
It's Rahul's group in Cambridge, published
in "Nature" last year, that activated platelets are really not
nice, and they produce all manner of bad prostaglandins, including thromboxane
A2, which we've known for a long time is a predictor of bad
outcomes in health. It turns out TXA2 hits your T
cells, and through the guanine receptor pathway, it
inhibits tumor response. And Rahul's team took out
RGF1 and negated that effect to demonstrate the point.
If you take aspirin, you permanently inactivate COX1, you take out
your activated platelets, and that enhances your
tumor response as a result. That was about two years of
reviewing and five years of research in one slide.
So where are all the canaries? One in 400 of the people in our UK Biobank are
supposed to be suffering from Lynch
syndrome, and yet when we set up
CAPP2, sorry, CAPP3, we could find about 8,000 people
in our country with Lynch syndrome.
So we persuaded NICE to make it a requirement that all
people with colon cancer be tested for mismatch repair deficiency in their
tumor to help target people who might have Lynch syndrome.
And with my colleagues at the National Disease Registration Service,
we rather tiringly looked at all 37,662
colorectal cancers that happened in England in 2019, and we
found that only 43% of them had actually been tested by either
MSI or immunohistochemistry. And rather worryingly, only
210 of those people who were positive actually made it to a
germline test.
So that led our NHS England team to agree to fund a transformation
project, which is chaired by Kevin Monahan, and we've now got to more than
95% of our tumors being tested either by
IHC or by MSI testing. And I'm excited to
say that we can now require that all of the people with Lynch
syndrome be offered national bowel cancer screening colonoscopies.
These are the best of the best. They're very good equipment.
They're dedicated colonoscopists.
And they are now doing two yearly colonoscopies on all of our Lynch patients.
In order to find those people, we've now got permission to register
as a notifiable event, effectively, if you have Lynch syndrome in the
National Health Service in England, and we have a
registry in our National Disease
Registration Service. Clare Turnbull has led a wonderful Cancer Research
UK program, which culminated in the publication of this
paper in 2024, where we were able to track down the
12,292 proven carriers of Lynch syndrome who
live in England.
And they are now able to be tracked and of course, take part in
research. And a paper about to appear in "Gut,"
interestingly, will demonstrate that those who had colonoscopies more
frequently did not have fewer colon cancers,
something we can talk about later.
Our contribution to this is to invent a modern-day form
of microsatellite instability testing.
The old five-marker test doesn't run through next-gen sequences, so
we selected 14 highly variable ontogenic
markers and a Bayesian calculator, which means that you don't have to do
any hard work. You simply press the button, and if it's positive, it's
MSI. If it's negative, it's MSS. And the nice thing is
we've eradicated the irritating MSI load diagnoses that we had to
deal with. The other thing is we've added in BRAF V600E, which helps target
the ones most likely to be Lynch syndrome, and also 22 RAS
drivers. And as of next month or the month after, we'll also add in the
PIC3CA drivers. So you get everything in one go, one technologist,
3,000 tumors a year, and they receive and report all of
them. So that works very well. And it's so sensitive that we've now demonstrated
that it will work in urine.
And so we set up a trial regionally where we tested MSH2 gene
carriers and found 4 of 80 of them to have an
asymptomatic urothelial cancer.
We've now tested more than 300. It looks like we've got about a 99%
sensitivity and 98% specificity.
And we're now about, with the blessing of our Cancer Research UK Early
Detection Committee, I hope to start rolling that out nationally in
August. And indeed, we've got our first DNA sent over from the Dana-Farber
only last week. So that will hopefully be coming to a door near you.
These are the people who helped develop the MSIplus assay, which
is going to be commercially available, I have to declare, of course.
And these are the many hundreds of people who took part in the CAPP3 trial.
And that's of course, not to forget the 3,000 or so people with Lynch
syndrome who made this talk possible.
If you want to talk more about this, please come to our Cancer Prevention Research
conference in Atlanta.
And that's my 15 minutes finished. Thank you.
Thanks, John. I think we'll have a panel discussion at the end and take
questions.
Next speaker is Nora Disis from University of Washington in
Seattle. Nora's going to talk about vaccines for cancer
prevention and intervention.
Start.
There you go.
Thanks very much.
These are my disclosures.
You know, vaccines have been probably the most impactful
intervention in human health in the last 100 years.
If you think about it, 100 years ago, the reason why we died
was from infectious disease. Yet the advent of
vaccinesreally eradicated that.
Now we die from cardiovascular disease and cancer, and
through vaccines, we've been able to eliminate most of the
pathogens that really reduced our
lifespan. And the reason why this happened is because of
the unique characteristics of vaccines.
All vaccines induce an adaptive immune
response, and that adaptive immune response has T
cells and B cells that are specific to an
antigen, an immunogenic protein that's expressed
somewhere in the body. This makes that immune response
very precise, selective, and most
vaccines are associated with very little toxicity related to
the antigen.
T cells, now we're talking about cancer, that's the most
important lymphocyte for tumor eradication,
can travel anywhere in the body. So whenever that
disease would pop up, you'll have a T cell there to recognize it.
Because another thing the immune system generates is
immunologic memory. That's why you can get vaccinated and 10
years later, be exposed to a pathogen and be able to eradicate
it before you even knew you had an exposure.
And finally, one of the benefits of vaccines for
cancer prevention is you can get all this with
a limited number of exposures to the vaccine, one or two
or three, and have lifelong immunity.
So we're at a tipping point specifically for cancer
vaccines targeting non-viral antigens.
And we're at a tipping point for four reasons.
First, we know that we need type one T cells, both CD4
and CD8 T cells, to eradicate cancer, that
are capable of being able to stimulate this type of response and make T
cells that are capable of penetrating tumors.
Further, hundreds of tumor antigens have been identified.
Mutated antigens, shared antigens.
You can literally tailor-make a cancer vaccine for any tumor.
We have very safe and effective vaccine
delivery technologies, which are nucleic acid-based.
And we're really dealing with more appropriate patient populations.
When you go back to infectious disease, there isn't any infectious
disease vaccine you'd use to actually treat cancer.
And as we see more successes or
inklings of success in terms of therapeutic vaccines,
vaccines have moved more and more into the prevention setting.
And what I'm going to show you today are clinical trials that are
ongoing of cancer vaccines in the prevention setting.
And there are three ways we do this.
We use vaccines for interception of
pre-invasive lesions. Now, this is the
highest bar. It's a therapeutic vaccine.
You're immunizing someone with a disease to make that
disease go away. Next, you have the
classic way that we immunize. That's primary
prevention, prophylaxis, immunizing
patients that have never had cancer, but probably are
at high risk. And then the final topic I want to
introduce very briefly is the idea of vaccination to
reduce cancer risk, and this is a new area
of vaccines. And what I have here is a list of tumors
with well-defined, pre-invasive
lesions, well-defined high-risk groups.
And you can find a preventive cancer vaccine for almost
every tumor on this slide.
So let's start with interception.
Probably the first clinical trials for cancer
interception took place for ductal carcinoma in situ.
DCIS, very common, accounts for 20% of all breast
cancer diagnoses.
But only 10% to 15% of DCIS will develop invasive
cancer if you leave them untreated.
The problem is that when they do develop invasive
cancer, they don't always come back locally, they can come back systemically.
So surgery and radiation, which we use to treat DCIS,
prevent local recurrence, but may not necessarily improve
overall survival because of that coming
back as a systemic disease. Now, 30% to 40% of
DCIS overexpress the protein HER2, which
is a well-known tumor antigen in breast cancer, and it also happens
to be associated with an increased risk of progression to
invasive breast cancer from DCIS.
Brian Susnik at UPenn was the first to really
vaccinate patients to try to eradicate DCIS, and
he did it with a very early study of a small number of patients,
giving them their own autologous dendritic cells loaded with
HER2/neu epitopes internodally to make
sure that these antigens went directly to the lymph nodes to
stimulate the T cells in kind of a window of opportunity study
before they had definitive surgery.
And he showed two important concepts.
First,
the vaccines induced very significant levels of type one T
cells and antibodies. But secondly, seven of the
11 evaluable patients actually lost expression of
HER2/neu on their DCIS, so they eliminated the
target,
and he saw T cells involved in the DCIS.
He subsequently went on to expand these studies and showed
that he could generate pathologic complete responses
in about 30% of DCIS patients that were
HER2/neu positive and estrogen receptor negative.
And now many others are using HER2/neu-based vaccines
to treat DCIS. There's a clinical trial of a MUC1
vaccine to treat DCIS, and a multi-antigen
vaccine that will hit both ER positive and ER negative
LCIS and DCIS
is about to enter clinical trials in this
area.So how would you develop a
prophylactic vaccine where you didn't have the tumor,
and you couldn't pick the antigens from the tumor?
Well, one way is to look at patients who are genetic high risk
and try to find commonalities of the tumors that
they develop. And so, a study that was just published,
which was quite interesting, was prophylactic vaccination for
Lynch syndrome, most common cause of inherited colon and
endometrial cancer,
younger age and multiple cancers.
And the type of pathologic variants in the MMR
repair genes that you just heard about really dictate where
that cancer's going to come up, so very difficult to screen for.
And the risk varies by mutation.
So one of the commonalities in this group
of tumors when they arise is that they develop frameshift
mutations. And it was shown by a group in the Netherlands that
these frameshift mutations are immunogenic and can act
as neoantigens. And they can be predicted and used in vaccines,
and they have been for about a decade in terms of looking at
a person's particular mutation and trying to
tailor-make precision vaccines for that individual
patient.
But Eduardo Villar Sanchez headed a study, it was
just published in "Nature Medicine," where a vaccine called
NAUS209 took 209
frameshift mutations, so this vaccine could be off the
shelf. And what they did is they put them in viral
vectors. One was a great ape adenovirus,
so something your immune system had never seen before, it would be very foreign.
And the boost vaccine was with a modified Ankara
virus, so the two did not neutralize each other.
Forty-five people were enrolled, subjects with Lynch syndrome,
high-grade dysplasia, cervical cancer they did not have.
So these were people right, walking in off the door.
And the primary endpoints of the study were safety and
immunogenicity. They had an 8%
grade 3 adverse event rate, which was really related to the
first immunization, the priming immunization with that great ape
vaccine. And afterwards, they had
very few adverse events. And the adverse events were very similar to what you'd see
with any vaccine, headache, fatigue, nausea,
myalgia.
And most interestingly, 100% of the
patients developed immunity to some of the frameshift
mutations. And in fact, the immunity
persisted in the vast majority,
85% over a year, after just a single
prime and a single boost immunization.
That's really great immunogenicity of this approach.
And when you look at that pink circle, they had so many antigens,
they had to test them in pools. You can see most of the
patients were responding to multiple antigens in those
pools. So this highly immunogenic vaccine will be
moving on to phase two studies to really look at cancer prevention.
The final couple of slides I want to show you is the concept of
reducing cancer risk by
quelling or quenching chronic inflammation.
And chronic inflammation is a common cause of many cancers.
About 30% of cancers can be linked to chronic
inflammation. And one of the places where we see type one
inflammation commonly is in metabolic obesity,
where hypertrophic adipocytes cause
metabolic stress, create a microenvironment that's very
favorable to activating innate immune cells and
making them antigen-presenting cells.
And the proteins within the adipocytes become
abnormal and highly upregulated, and they actually act as
antigens. And what happens is you get antigen
presentation, you get an adaptive immune response.
That environment makes that continue, accelerates it,
and you're fighting for nutrients. You create metabolic dysfunction.
The T cells become dysfunctional.
They can't immune surveil. When the cancer comes up, you
eventually develop EMT, and you end up with
cancer.
Our group's been working on type one selective vaccines, but
we've also begun to create anti-inflammatory vaccines.
And we identified many of these upregulated proteins found in
adipocytes and created a vaccine directed to about
six of these proteins called adipocyte-directed
vaccines, that specifically elicits T cells that
secrete high levels of IL-10, IL-4, and
IL-5. So you can see, going back to precision
prevention, being able to directly
target these vaccines where the inflammation is
in the adipocytes.
And I'll just end up with this slide of two models of this
adipocyte-directed vaccine. One is
in diabetes, the diabetes
model of obesity, and the other is in a model
of breast cancer, the TgMMTV-PyM mouse, that
when you make these animals obese, they develop their breast cancers more quickly,
and they develop multifocal breast cancers.
You can see in this model, when you start feeding them a high-fat diet
at 10 weeks, they become obese, and then we
vaccinate them with this adipocyte vaccine.The
Advac vaccine compared to the sham vaccine control
really reduces the amount of CD8 T cells that are found in the
visceral fat. These CD8 T cells are what's
driving this immune proliferation.
And you can see we're getting to the point where we're correcting it
nearly to lean. What you'd like to see in normal fat
are high levels of T regulatory cells, and you can see
in Advac immunized animals, their T regulatory
cell level in the visceral fat is coming back to what you'd see
in lean. And finally, these animals develop insulin
insensitivity and frank diabetes, and you can see compared
to sham vaccine versus Advac, we're beginning to
correct their ability to handle their glucose and
changing that insulin insensitivity.
And here in the FEB-new mice, you can see in the
same model, this time going out a much longer time, that
animals that become obese and have the sham vaccine
all develop tumors by 30 weeks. Animals who get the Advac
vaccine, 60% of them are still tumor-free at 30
weeks, and they've reduced their leptin levels, which are
associated with the EMT transformation.
So finally, I think in the next few years, we're rapidly going to be
seeing more vaccines coming in for cancer prevention.
They're already in the clinic right now.
They're already in phase two studies.
And I think it's important as we team up with trying to define
what is high risk and what are the levels of high risk,
there will be vaccines for people at every level, vaccines to
prevent disease recurrence, vaccines to treat
interception for those who have high-risk lesions, frank
prophylactic vaccines for people who've never had cancer,
and risk-reducing vaccines, not only directed against chronic
inflammation, but other risk factors for cancer.
Thank you.
Thanks, Nora. Our last speaker in this session is
Joanne Elmore from UCLA School of Medicine.
She's going to speak about AI in cancer diagnosis, promise and
performance,
and the human AI factor.
And my goal is to have you develop a healthy
skepticism about AI.
My talk will emphasize two areas where we need to do better,
and I think AI can help.
Then I'm going to quickly go over some examples of AI work, but talk
about challenges. And then I want to conclude with the
important and understudied topic of the human
AI interaction.
These are my disclosures.
Starting with
the first area that I think AI can help us, risk prediction models.
They work really well at a population, but not so
well at the individual patient level.
Years ago, I asked the following question.
For example, breast cancer risk models, how well do they work
in categorizing individual women as average versus high
risk for developing invasive breast cancer? I'm an internist.
I use the models in my clinic.
I took three commonly used models, used every day in the US
and internationally. I applied them to the same 31,000 women.
I estimated five-year risk.
As you would guess, they worked great at the accuracy at the
population level, discrimination, calibration.
This is what's commonly reported.
And I found that more than 21% of the women were classified as high
risk by all three models.
But
let me show you the Venn diagram of all of the women that were
identified by at least one model.
Not much overlap.
These are our current actively used risk prediction models.
What does this mean clinically? It means if I'm in clinic and I
use one risk model on one woman, another risk model on the second woman,
I may share with them different comments and different
recommendations.
The second area that we have a challenge, but
where I hope AI can help, is in diagnostic
accuracy. An earlier study,
I took mammograms
and asked radiologists to independently interpret them.
These weren't medical students or residents.
These were actively practicing radiologists.
They gave me different interpretations.
You can see the range here. Now, this is just a single case, but in this
study, I showed them 150
mammograms.
I could, in the paper, report Kappa statistics, et cetera, but to me,
clinically, if one radiologist says,
"Routine follow-up in a year or two," and the other says, "Get a biopsy," that's
clinically significant. That happened in 25% of these cases.
Now, I realized I was actually assuming if they recommended a biopsy,
they were recommending it in the same breast, but women have two breasts,
and that happened in 9% of the cases.
I spent about 10 years studying human decision-making of
radiologists, and I'm going to share a personal story of how I
and why I transitioned to pathology.
My dermatologist called me late on a Friday night and said, "Joanne,
I hate calling patients with this kind of news, but..."
And I'm a physician. I knew what that meant.
I, in a skin biopsy, had invasive
melanoma.We obtained a second opinion on the
pathology, and they said, "Oh, no, it's benign." So then we sent it to a third
pathologist who said, "Oh, it's just a complicated Spitz lesion." And I
realized all of my prior research
in radiology had been based on the outcome of cancer,
yes or no. And I thought, "I need to study this."
So we did. We recruited US pathologists,
actively practicing,
and had them interpret cases independently.
We've done this in breast and in skin biopsies.
Our gold standard, we recruited world experts.
And
on the topic, they independently interpreted the cases and came
up with our reference consensus diagnosis.
But I will admit it was a bit like a Mad Hatter
tea party. And let me share the results with you.
This is just one skin biopsy case. The glass slide
was sent around the US, and 36 pathologists
kindly participated because they care about this.
They want us to do better. Look at the variability, though.
They're all looking at the same glass slide.
Only 10 agreed with the consensus of the
experts.
This is only one case. This shows you the results for
240 cases, 187 pathologists,
almost 9,000 interpretations. The Y-axis is the
percent concordance with the reference.
You could say it's accuracy if you trust our reference.
On the X-axis, you'll see the class one cases that the
experts called benign. Pretty much the US
pathologists agree. But look on the far right, the invasive melanomas.
More than 20% of the time, US pathologists were downgrading
and misclassifying.
Now, one part of our design was that it was
two phases. We took the same cases.
They interpreted them in phase one.
We gave them a six-month washout period.
We renumbered them and sent them to the same pathologist.
So the question is: will they give the same diagnosis?
If they would, it would all be at 100% when you're
comparing their phase one with their phase two.
I'm going to show you the results, and this is where I think AI can be helpful.
AI might at least be reproducible.
You can see here that
they didn't always agree
when they interpreted the same case in phase two with the diagnosis they had
given in phase one.
Because canaries were mentioned earlier, I want to show a picture of a pigeon.
Pigeons are trainable observers of images,
and in just two weeks, with reinforcement feeding, as
shown with the food pellets on the left, they can be taught, this is
two weeks, with fairly high accuracy to
peck whether it's breast cancer or not on these images.
If you attended this morning's plenary, you can see now AI can
do this in minutes.
So let's move into AI.
Probably 15 years ago, I started collaborating with engineers.
I would give them image data. They would then detect the
regions of interest. They would do tissue segmentation, and
they would spit out a diagnosis, and they
did quite well.
The red arrows point to the accuracy of
pathologists interpreting cases, their
sensitivity/specificity. And then this shows the results
of two AI models. One's called a tissue distribution
feature. The other is based on structure.
But I want to point out how old this is.
This was published seven years ago, and we were already doing well
then. Think what's happened just in the last months with AI.
Currently, I'm taking the image data shown here on the top left,
merging it with text data, the clinical words
around the images, and we're looking at survival
estimation. And what I like is that I don't understand the black
box, so I'm having the AI give me words to explain
why it's calling someone high risk versus low risk.
We're also adding in a pathologist, a human in the
loop, so that we can further understand the black box.
Now,
most importantly are a few areas that are challenges
in AI model development. The first is the gold
standard. When our statistician saw the amount
of diagnostic variability in a diagnosis of cancer, her first comment
was,
"Should we have had five experts,
or should we have had seven?" And basically, the outcome of the
woman, the clinical outcome, is what's most important, but once you've removed
a tissue, you might have changed the underlying
biology. And I think we're still struggling with the gold standard
outcome.
Second, the black box transparency.
If we don't understand it, as clinicians, will we trust it?
Third is so important, bias and generalizability.
I want to share a slide.
First of all,
this is an example on the left of an AI program that was built
to detect skin conditions. It worked quite well,
but as the authors pointed out,
a limitation was that their data in didn't include all skin
types. We need to make certain that our data
is generalizable.
A poignant example on the right was published in "Science," and this
one really bothers me. There's a lot of-bias in our health
data, and these authors
studied an algorithm that was
actively being used in US hospitals.
And this AI model was systematically
discriminating against black patients.
And the reason is that the bias in the model occurred because
the algorithm, it used health costs as a
proxy for health needs.
We need to assure that the development of AI tools
includes multidisciplinary teams, not silos,
and we need to be very cautious.
This brings me to my third area,
which is the human-computer interface, and
I don't feel like this is getting enough attention.
We humans don't always react and interact with computers the
way you think we would. And I'm going to explain why I'm interested
in this.
I worked at a county hospital, and one of my patients
asked me in clinic,
"Why are they charging me $45 for this extra computer thing on
my screening mammogram?" She was working two jobs, and I
thought it was a valid question.
At the time, I was working with the Breast Cancer Surveillance Consortium.
We had access to hundreds of thousands of screening mammograms,
and I looked, and I saw, oh, half had been interpreted with a computer-aided
detection program. The other half hadn't.
Let me see how much benefit we were
getting from that early computer-aided
detection program on screening mammograms.
This shows you the results. Simple ROC curve.
Black line at the top is the results for the hundreds of thousands of screening
exams with no computer use. Red dashed line,
results when the computer was used.
When the computer was used,
it was associated with significantly
lower
accuracy.
Not good.
After this publication, others reproduced the same,
and it didn't really change practice.
It was a moneymaker for many facilities, and
90%-plus of all mammograms were
using this older computer-aided detection program.
So this could've been harming patients.
Let me
discuss some hypotheses and some potential reasons why we
may have found that the computer was leading to harm.
First is automation bias.
Clinician may just want to go with whatever the AI says.
Radiologists care. They don't want to miss a cancer,
so if the computer marks an area, they may be hesitant to
not call the woman back for additional testing. The recall rate might go up.
Secondly,
we all get tired sometimes in the afternoon, and if
the computer program doesn't flag anything, maybe you'll assume it has your
back, and you may miss things.
We need to be cautious with this. Secondly,
de-skilling.
I'm very worried about de-skilling of our next generation of physicians.
All of the med students are using AI to help them figure
out a diagnosis.
I want to share with you that when I was typing notes for this talk,
there was an autocorrect when I typed de-skilling.
Doctors killing was what was typed.
It may be an overstatement, but it is a real concern to me.
And the final is the intent.
There's a lot of rah-rah AI, but is it
going to help our patients? We care.
We want it to help.
On that point, I'm involved in two ongoing studies.
The first is a prospective randomized trial
of AI in screening mammography called the PRISM Trial, funded by
PCORI, and we're testing the real-world
impact. The AI tool is Transpara by ScreenPoint
Medical. And the exams are being
randomized via a platform from Aidoc,
either to show the radiologist, "Here's an exam with AI" versus
just read the exam without. Our target enrollment is 400,000,
and we're already
accruing. We're at about 40,000 now.
Second study I'm involved in is a bit more granular on
the how clinicians are interacting with the AI.
I'm looking at topics such as what kind of AI
cue. Should the AI cue just put a box and
alert your attention visually, or should it give you the diagnosis?
On the right,
we're studying the timing of the AI cue.
At the top, you'll see
what we're doing in the PRISM mammography study, which is the
radiologist is given the AI information before they even
look at the exam.
That might be biasing them. There may be automation bias.
We don't know. At the bottom, I'm looking at delayed cue
presentation, in that clinician makes an
independent interpretation,
then they see the AI, and they can decide if they want to change their diagnosis.
In this study, we're also working with cognitive psychologists.
We're looking at eye tracking. What happens when there's different
types of cues?
How does that alter the time, et cetera?
So we're basically investigating real-world impact of AI
and how we clinicians are going to
interact with the AI
tools.In
summary,
I started describing
two domains
where I think we have challenges and we need to do better.
Risk prediction models, they work really good at the
population level, but
I'm seeing patients one-on-one. I want help.
I want them to do better
with my individual patient in the clinic.
Secondly, diagnostic accuracy. I've shown that it is
really hard, especially for those cases in the middle of the
diagnostic spectrum.
And I've also shown how we physicians are not always reproducible.
We may not give the same diagnosis if you give us six months
time period in between looking at the data.
Finally,
while AI tools hold great potential and I'm
optimistic,
they require rigorous evaluation.
We need to ensure that they're enhancing
and not disrupting the clinical care we're giving to patients.
Thank you.
Okay, I call all the speakers up to the stage, and we'll have a
panel discussion and take questions from the audience.
And there are microphones distributed in the aisles.
There's a question by Dr. Su over here.
I want to thank the
speakers for excellent presentations. I learned a lot.
And I guess a question for all the panelists and maybe Ray
as well. I think prevention
and early detection research is so important, and yet the funding
for research in this area is not easy.
And the attraction for pharmaceutical companies to go into this
area is even harder. How do we really
make this more
tractable? That more will invest in monies and funding and
attracting more research into this space, which is everything you've told
me to date. I feel like we should start thinking more about it tomorrow, or
today even, and yet it's so hard to implement these areas of
research.
Good question. I can start.
Clearly, I think all of the funding for the last two or three
decades has really been focused on treatment because that's the patient
you get in the clinic, and they're in dire need of something to overcome the
disease. But if you look at statistics and populations,
clearly we can have a rapid impact in
prevention and early detection compared to getting
those successful treatments and cures on board.
And there's no reason why we can't do both, but my feeling is that
we have been underfunding the prevention side of things.
So I welcome anybody to make comments.
Can I say, one in 25 of the people who got aspirin in the CAP2 trial
didn't get a bowel cancer, but they don't know that they didn't get a cancer.
You don't get thanked by the people who didn't get cancer.
So it's a slightly thankless area.
But also, in the pharmaceutical industry, you can't make
a living out of prevention, basically.
This can only work if it's driven by centrally
government-funded research, or funding, because it's very hard for it
to defend, with the possible exception of the vaccine
model.
I think so. I think government's needed there, too.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
I think vaccines are kind of the poster child of
not being able to get anywhere because at the point where they're starting
to show some efficacy,
pharmaceuticals are not so interested in the type of vaccines
you give three times and never use again or end up
using once a year. There might be some interest in those highly
personalized vaccines that are being given almost like a therapeutic,
where people are getting them all the time.
But these are very low-cost
interventions, and I think that governments
have to step in as a health
service, health improvement.
Thanks. Joanne?
On the topic of how to get more funding,
I run a training program. It's called The Clinical Scholars Program.
It's a follow-up of the Robert Wood Johnson Clinical Scholars Program,
and I realize that part of our curriculum needs to be communication.
We scientists have done a terrible job.
We need to learn how to frame.
We need to learn about the power of the clinical vignette,
and it's hard. And so I think going forward, part of
all of our training needs to be communication skills.
And then when someone else figures out the funding, let me know, please.
Okay, Andy, I think you have some questions.
Yeah. That was a great session. Thank you for all the speakers.
I wanted to ask-
Your mic's not on.
Your mic. Maybe you need to turn it on, Andy.
Try it again.
Where?
It's on.
Now.
It's on now, I think.
No, thank you for a really great session. So I have two questions.
One is, as
Nora and
John had spoken about, there seems to be this growing kind of convergence
of inflammation and immunity for cancer prevention.
So I was curious to hear your perspectives on combination
strategies. I know there have been some discussion around that and maybe using
NSAIDs or aspirins as adjuvants for vaccines and
whether those are potential approaches that we should be considering.
And then the second question was, as we think about
pediatric screening and think about
identifying high-risk populations earlier, how do we also
consider options for prevention
in childhood, especially as we are starting to see more of these sort of early
onset cancers? Do we start to think about vaccinations or
anti-inflammatory drugs at even younger ages?
Do you want to take the first one?
Okay, several questions.
You want to take the first one?
So I think that NSAIDs are great adjuvants to
vaccines, and we've published that they can actually synergize
with vaccines and augment the immune response,
as was alluded to as well. And, for
the second question, just briefly, I worry a lot
about how we can get vaccines into children
earlier. So for example, I'm working on a vaccine for
familial adenomatous polyposis.
And once the horse is out of the barn there, it's going to be very
difficult to look at anything but a reduction in
polyps. But it may be that if you can get
children 10 years, nine years, and be able to
vaccinate them, you might be able to prevent them
from ever getting the hundreds and hundreds of polyps that they get.
So it would be bad for me to
wait another 50 years to try to get everything
now to be able to go into children, and I think that that's
something where conversations have to start early.
Okay.
As part of Alex Lemonade Stand, the other grant that was
funded the same time as us is actually looking in
a very high-risk disorder, which is the recessive
version of Lynch, constitutional mismatch repair deficiency.
And their goal there is to try to use a
vaccination approach because the cancer risk
is so high in those children.
The other thing there's a lot of interest in is not
prevention, but liquid biopsy screening instead of--
Every time we do a whole body MRI, the young child has to be
anesthetized. And so that's a very expensive
procedure with some morbidity. And so the hope is that
perhaps
circulating tumor DNA may be able to replace some of the
surveillance we're doing, but that's a very complicated
effort which is underway at a number of organizations.
Could I just do a-- First of all, I absolutely endorse, as you know,
Andy, that aspirin and vaccine go together.
And in fact, the LynchVax trial, which we'll be supporting David
Church from Oxford,
will be including aspirin as well as vaccinating using the
Moderna mRNA approach. I've worked for a long time with
Nuscom. It was originally set up by Riccardo Cortesi.
The great thing about that vaccine is that the two viruses that
were described
were actually first developed for the Ebola vaccine.
So we had a huge amount of historic safety data, which is great.
Our slight worry is that the likelihood of this needing
recurrent use raises the question of whether those
adenoviruses, second time around, you'll have seen it coming.
And so we might see a decline in efficacy.
So I think the new RNA viruses offer us a really great opportunity.
But also, just need to thank Riccardo Cortesi for his
vision to actually get us this far.
And then we have two folks over here on the left side.
And you're right in our light sign of sight, so sorry
about that.
That's okay. Yeah, thank you for including pediatrics in this
session. I'm a pediatric oncologist, and I'm really interested in
this intersection between pediatrics and adult medicine.
You mentioned, Dr. Bryne, that a five-year start on the
first colonoscopy would be a good place to start
early intervention with low-dose aspirin.
That brings us into the pediatric years.
So we're going to have to sort of develop communication skills, as was
mentioned, to think about prevention, maybe in the general pediatric
space.
Lynch is fairly common, and thinking about how we would roll
that out if that became a standard of care, I bet the UK will
precede us on that and teach us a lot about how to do that as a public
health intervention.
Comment. Next person?
Yeah, thank you very much. Wonderful session. Suzanne Delaloge from France.
I have a question regarding how you foresee the development of the
new prevention vaccines and new
strategies in terms of accelerating.
What type of endpoint especially should we pick?
Mortality incidents or surrogate endpoints that were so
successful with HPV vaccines based on the rarity
or frequency of the situation? If it's DCIS, might be a bit
different of
Lynch syndrome cancers, for instance.
Maybe you could just
repeat the question in a shorter-
Shorter. How do you foresee phase three trials
in cancer prevention regarding the endpoints, especially?
Yeah.
The endpoints for phase twos can be very varied.
So for instance,
many phase twos, especially in genetic high-risk
people, are looking for T cells
trafficking to the tissue where
the tumors are meant to be developed.
Or,
let's say in BRCA1 or BRCA2 gene mutation carriers,
trying to immunize during a year or two years
prior to prophylactic surgery, and
then in larger trials, comparing what you would see as an
insipient lesion to potential control.
But this is a big area of
research, is trying to figure out what are some shorter
endpoints that would allow prioritization of
vaccines-
Yeah
... to take on to larger trials. And of course, going back to
Like circulating
liquid biopsies or tumor DNA to try to find
that biologic surrogate that would
allow not to have to go to a 10-year or 20-year
endpoint on a clinical trial with loads and loads of patients.
Like circulating MSI or something.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
Rick, could I just?
Yeah, sure.
Before the session, we were discussing my canary analogy, and I was saying that
the point about canaries is not just to save the canaries, but to save the
people with them. And I think one of the attractions of our new
national registry of people with Lynch syndrome and other hereditary cancers is we
can work with you guys. We can do these trials at scale with people
who've got very high penetrance disease, and therefore, we have a tractable
endpoint. And we don't always have the money for the research, but we have an
awful lot of willing patients. And crucially, we can track them at very
little cost because all of the cancers get notified anyway.
So we can track the cancers indefinitely in people, as we've just done for the
gallery trial with Grail.
So I encourage partnership. I realize it's politically a
bit more sensitive at the moment, but we can do things on our side of the water
that just aren't feasible on this side.
Okay. A question in the middle.
Hi. First of all, thank you for your talk. It was very informative.
I was wondering specifically on NSB screening, what you think the most
influential factor is in determining inclusion
in NSB screening efforts. Is it disease severity or
prevalence or treatability of
conditions? Just wondering what you thought the most influential
factor would be there.
Can you
talk a little closer to the microphone and repeat that?
Sorry.
Hard to hear what you say.
Okay.
I was wondering in NSB screening specifically, what you thought the most
influential factor is in inclusion in NSB screening
panels. So would that be disease severity or
treatability or prevalence in
younger populations?
So Sharon, how do you decide what to include in your panel?
Yeah.
So it's one of the things geneticists love to argue about
are genes.
And so
fortunately, there have been enough studies now, as I mentioned, I just showed
data from ours, but there are St. Jude, many different
organizations, Canada, have published their results.
So we have a very good idea in children with solid
tumors what genes you are likely to find a
variant.
And I'll give an example. ALK is an example that is
associated with an increased risk of neuroblastoma, but it is
actually very rarely reported in our studies.
So you could include it. You're not going to spend that much more money for
one more gene. But let's say it was a very large gene
with multiple exons. You might really think twice about including a gene where you
almost never find a cause-- you never find it in
cohorts of patients.
I will say, and I was thinking of talking to Lisa afterwards, what we did ignore
actually are some of the very rare recessive disorders
that have very high rates of cancer
but are individually extraordinarily rare.
Now, that doesn't stop other newborn screening.
Many of the metabolic disorders are one in a million babies.
So then you have to really decide, would we have picked up that child
anyway? Would they have had congenital anomalies? Would they have microcephaly?
But would a pediatrician actually have noticed that?
So I think you do have to be a little bit more realistic about healthcare,
at least in the United States, and not always say, "Well, it would've been
picked up anyway." So for example, the
early lists of secondary findings did not include NF1
because they said, well, people should've been diagnosed based on the features.
But we all know that many patients have that disorder and are
never diagnosed. So we try to take sort of a realistic
approach to, would this child have otherwise been
diagnosed, and are there cancer rates
in early childhood? So we, for example, did not include
BRCA1. We didn't include BRCA2, which
a poster of my student does have a small increased risk of adult
tumors, but that risk is very low. So there are multiple sort
of qualifications to the list.
But everyone comes up with slightly different lists is what I would say, and
so that's because our data's not perfect.
I think Joanne has a comment.
In cancer screening, for example, in
our randomized clinical trial of screening mammography with
versus without AI, we asked the patients.
It's funded by PCORI, and so patients said, "Of course,
we want you to detect cancers earlier." So that's one of our
primary outcomes.
But we're screening healthy populations.
Remember, first, do no harm. So we actually have two
primary outcomes in our randomized clinical trial.
The second one is the recall rate.
The women that we spoke with when we were designing the trial, some of them had
had false positive exams.
10% of exams, the women are called back for additional
testing. Screening mammography, it's a screening test.
It's very common in the US, but
women get anxious when they get a phone call that says, "Dear Mrs.
Smith, don't worry, but you may have breast cancer.
Please come back for more testing."
So we want to assure as our secondary outcome that the recall rate does not
go up with the AI, and we're hoping it may even go down.
Thank you.
Thank you. And last question over here.
Hi. Yeah. I have two quick questions. For Dr.
Elmore, as you're learning from all the research about these biases,
how are you thinking about
In your teaching of clinicians who are learning about
medicine,
how we make sure that they learn about things like automation bias as they're
taking up these tools. And then if there's time for Dr.
Byrne, I'm just curious if you can elaborate a bit more about the Plan UK
guideline and that sequencing of the aspirin and the colonoscopy.
Are you saying, for example, if someone was 45, you would put them on
aspirin for a while before you would do the colonoscopy? So, okay. Sorry.
The answer to how we
help train the next generation of physicians,
it's evolving.
I'm working with medical students trying to teach them how to use our
ambient scribes when I'm in with a patient.
I push a button on my phone, and it transcribes
everything, but there's errors
. There's an AI summary of each patient that
gives a text with little reference links that I can
click on, and it will take me to that 287-page
PDF to the actual page that I need to see, the PET scan
summary. I like it, but it's not perfect.
It has errors, and it forgets about timing, and it's telling me my
60-year-old woman is pregnant. So I'm trying to
work with the students and be a partner with
them as we all learn how to use these.
Most of the students at my institution are using
open evidence,
and I am worried. I truly am worried.
So I think instead of ignoring this, we need to work with them.
Sure, have them use an AI tool,
but then also teach them about just because there's one paper, is that
paper adequate? Let's talk about quality of evidence.
But this is an important question that all of the medical
training institutions for students and residents needs
to quickly improve our curriculum.
John, you can clear up the colonoscopy.
Yeah. Thanks for raising that. I'm sorry I sort of hurried past it.
No, the idea is that since there's a four to five-year time lag
before you see a benefit, if you're going to start colonoscopy at
25, as we do in the MSH2 and MSH1 gene carriers, we're suggesting
starting the aspirin
five years before that, at 20. And in MSH6 and
PMS2, we'll start the aspirin at 30.
The side effect profile in the young population is very, very
small. The problem that physicians have is they meet mostly very
old people who get lots of side effects from aspirin.
It's 100 times more dangerous to take an aspirin at 80 than it is at 40.
So, we've got to sort of remember these are much younger people, and we should be
ideally treating people before they hit 50 or
60.
And we'll see the maximum benefit from doing it that
way. So I hope that is clear. The other thing, can I just reinforce,
I know you do annual colonoscopies.
There is no evidence in support of that, and in fact, we've
now got growing evidence that annual colonoscopies increases
diagnoses. It's actually you're getting an over-diagnosis because
the immune system is pretty good at taking out very highly
immunogenic lesions, and almost certainly an awful lot of these cancers would have
gone away of their own accord. So all of the evidence suggests, and we've got
now some registry data coming out, that basically two-yearly
colonoscopy is plenty frequent enough for these patients, and it is
not totally-- Not only is the cost of it, there is the cost to the patient
because in the very best of hands, colonoscopy will occasionally cause serious
bleeds and even death. And so we should be looking to
down or reduce the frequency of colonoscopy if at all possible.
We're now running a trial in Europe where we're going to see if we dare go to what
the Fins have always done, which is three-yearly colonoscopy.
And so Lynch is just launching. We're going to see whether we can actually
push it out even further. Because the whole premise of why we do it so
frequently is that in Lynch syndrome, you probably don't really get
a polyp like you'd normally see down a colonoscope.
You get a sessile swelling or even nothing at all.
And with our Heidelberg colleagues, we've published the argument that many of these
cancers just arrive as cancer. And so it's not that you missed it, it
just wasn't there.
But the point is the immune system holds it for a long time, so metastasis is
really quite a late event. So I would urge you to push towards less
frequent colonoscopy, but certainly start the aspirin earlier.
And I'll allow one last question.
Thank you.
Great session.
Connie Trimble, Johns Hopkins. Could you envision a-
Come closer to the microphone.
Can you speak up?
Could you envision
a clinical setting in which it would be useful to look at amniotic
fluid in a routine?
Because we get it's-
You really have to talk louder.
We can't hear you, sorry.
Can you envision any kind of clinical setting in which
it might be useful to screen on amniotic fluid?
Amniotic fluid screening.
Amniotic fluid.
Well, I
have many colleagues that have worked on prenatal genetics,
and we can do prenatal genomes even.
There's been a huge debate about reporting
cancer risk genes. I think certainly now
with disorders like retinoblastoma, I could see that
certainly being reported, and it's certainly done in
families where the mutation's known.
Again, the risk, the likelihood you're going to find something
is extremely low in a population and the risks of that
procedure. The advantage of adding it to newborn screening is
the child's getting the heel stick anyway, and so all you're doing is
adding the test, which has its own burden, but you're not
adding an additional procedure.
Okay. Well, I want to thank all the speakers.
They've done a fantastic job.
And also all the attendees. This is a really good bunch
of questions, and I think it clarified some things.
Thank you very much, and thanks, Dr. Su, for allowing us to have this.
Thank you.